what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
2024 I'm so happy to be sitting with the
team behind ghost light your movie blew
me away I genuinely mean that I'm
obsessed with the idea that I find it
easier to process difficult human truths
through storytelling and that's
literally what your movie is
congratulations and thank you thank you
so much thank you before I ask you a
bajillion questions about the making of
this movie I need to give a special
shout out to to filo our wonderful
sponsor who allows us to be here and
support independent film making they are
breaking barriers by putting the power
to Greenlight movies in the hands of
fans and creators if you want to learn
more about filo please check out their
website
film. can you repeat that can you do the
intro yes oh my God welcome back to filo
today we have a very special meeting
filo welcome back to filo I'm Katherine
cuper your host for the day and we have
a very special meeting with the ghost
light cast
we would like to give a special shout
out as they are breaking barriers in the
film Community really good can we keep
you here can you just do that intervie
cut that out of the footage and just put
it at the head of every single interview
we do the rest of the day we would love
it very all right Kelly I have to give
you the hardest question it's the
synopsis question because a lot of
people out there are going to first
learn about your film through the
Festival so in case someone out there
does not know what Ghostlight is about
can you give a Des yeah it's about a
construction worker who joins a
community theater production of Romeo
and Juliet and sort of the drama on
stage begins to mirror his real life job
well done good Bing you are very
prepared I always love when someone has
like distinct clear picture yeah it took
us a while to come up with it a lot of
texting a lot of texting and that was
the winner a question for both of you
now and correct me if I'm wrong on any
of this but I'm curious what it was like
figuring out what roles you would assume
on this film because because on the last
one Alex you directed and Kelly you
wrote and starred in it so why switch
things up a little bit here I knew that
I wanted to direct with Alex that was
something that because even on St
Francis our collaboration kind of wasn't
as um cleancut as just like director and
actor we're we're super collaborative in
the way that we work and I knew that I
didn't want to act in this one that I
just wanted to write and that I wanted
to direct as well and Alex is a really
amazing director and producer and so I
really wanted to work with him yeah is
there any new tool in your directing
toolkit by having experienced
co-directing with someone oh certainly I
think I thought that I had an assumption
that probably most people do which is
that if you're co-directing you're sort
of breaking things up and you know
between the two of you you've got one
director but really we became quite
unified and so it was essentially like
having 200% of directing and uh I think
new toolkit
uh what did you learn anything I guess I
have to talk to actors now right that's
but it's fun I learned um no no I think
uh I think just being sitting back
letting things play out you know um
trust all things that have always been
there but I think working working with
another person kind of takes you out of
your ego even more so so which leads to
great work I think so one more question
for the two of you before I throw it to
your wonderful Ensemble here I'm always
fascinated to hear about the experience
of getting a green light on your second
feature after a successful first feature
cuz I feel like a lot of people out
there might assume like once you make
one good one it's easy when that is not
necessarily the case so what is a
misconception about what it takes to get
a second film off the ground just that
it's easy and that you can you know we
had a lot of critical success with St
Francis and it doesn't necessarily mean
that the money starts rolling in yeah
you really just don't shouldn't wait for
anybody like don't wait for anybody
because nobody's nobody's coming for you
and just we raised all the money
ourselves so we essentially green lit
ourselves and that was nice and this was
supposed to be our third feature there
was a second one that we've been trying
to make ever since St Francis with you
know a bigger budget and uh it took a
long time and then the strike happened
and we pivoted and were able to move to
this one which is supposed to be our
third which is much scrappier than what
our second was supposed to be do you
have high hopes to Circle back to that
other one it's Mouse yeah that's right
yeah I my homework good work like I knew
I was going to want to see more from you
after watch this thank you yeah
hopefully that one will get made
eventually as all right I like I love
the idea of film making families just in
general the fact that you're a literal
family is blowing my mind right now I
want to ask a question that was deemed
kind of like a no no question in the
movie can you each give me a unique
technique you use to learn your lines
oh that's going to be hard for my mom
cuz that takes her while to learn her
lines wow wow thr under the bus that
really wasn't the question wow that was
just
context uh I uh I uh have somewhat of a
photographic memory so I just look at
them and they stay in my head true it's
the most annoying thing ever when we run
when he runs lines with us he learns
them within like 30 seconds your lines
and then when you ask for call line he's
like how do you not know this makes you
want to punch him in the face truly and
she does punch me in the face several
times why I look this
way oh my God this was a beautiful
script and so the lines came really
easily a lot of folks have asked us uh
along the Journey of Sundance if we
improvised a lot and the truth is we
didn't no because the text that Kelly
provided was always right there for us
and it it came very easily I for me
personally it came very easily and um
when you ground yourself in the
circumstance of the story the words were
just right there for you so it was
seamless and all we had to do every day
was show up and it just worked that's
one of the highest compliments ever when
someone assumes you improvise because
it's so damn natural yeah yeah they made
the words sound good there are some
clunker lines in there that they just
sold really
well
I have that for you Catherine give me a
give me a tip or trick you use well I
would I get like if I'm trying to
memorize multiple scenes that's harder
for me so I would try to like memorize
one and then once we shot that one I
would go on and memorize the next scene
so that I wasn't like having to think
about
multiple two different like scenes two
different lines yes one moment at a time
one moment at a time she did Shakespeare
yeah we pre we did prep did I prepped
Shakespeare um cuz I I do have some
Shakespeare monologues in it and I
started doing that before we started
filming so that I was kind of a head on
that part very much appreciate the the
one scene at a time approach because
like even prepping for interviews at
Sundance I'm like one day at a time one
day at a time and appreciate the moment
I want to ask a personal question for
all of you based on what you're
exploring in this movie I already
brought up the idea that you know part
of the reason why I love movies and just
storytelling in General is because
sometimes I find it easier to process
things I'm going through via a fictional
story on screen so for each of you can
you name a movie that you came across
that I don't know came into your life
just when you needed it and really
helped you through something man I I
could say I I got broken up with in New
York a long time ago and I remember
walking into an art housee theater and
seeing like a 2 p.m screening of Sophia
Copla somewhere and like no one was in
there except for
like two or three retirees and um I just
like baled and it was exactly what I
needed and I I felt so alone and I came
out feeling kind of quietly a little
less so and that was that was a great
movie moment for me I'll never forget
that like I could probably picture you
at like the quad or something sitting
there I think it was I think it was
there there's like bad seats in this
theater like like like there's colums so
like you could have a bad seat which is
unusual for a movie theater to get on
those Sophia CA train Lost in
Translation was that for me I think I
saw it in college when I was feeling
very a drift and I felt very um just in
line with Scarlet Johansson's character
and in terms of her kind of like
loneliness and and trying to find her
way in a world that she didn't really
understand good examples right
there
Catherine has to be Sophia cop that's
right let talk about something you love
the couple movies that I love I think
Stand By Me is one of my my favorite
movies one of my favorite movies of all
time I really love that one um I I I
think I like it a lot because of the
group of kids that and they're like and
and how be they become so much strong
you know closer with each other as as
the movie takes place I I really do love
that movie and um I love River Phoenix
too so that's another reason I watch
that one mildly disturbing but yes I
think that's really really and I haven't
I never read the Stephen King book or
the short story highly recomend yeah so
I'm going to try and read that one soon
but I watch Stand By Me Like con I mean
I've rewatched it probably like 15 times
just to add to that you also made
another movie that's probably that is
having that effect on tons of people out
there that's another are you there God
it's me Margaret I have been so so happy
to see all the award season love so well
right now as it should as it should yeah
and uh Kelly Freeman Craig is doing
really really really well and that's
really welld deserved I think that she
was an amazing director and writer and
so I'm really excited to see everyone
doing so well yeah well she just said
mine uh so happy the Judy Bloom book are
you there God it's me Margaret was a
really pivotal uh moment for me when I
read it in third grade and I felt like
it really prepared me in such a
beautiful way for what was coming um and
then I went on of course to read all of
Judy Bloom's books and when we were on
Set uh making the movie I had the
opportunity to meet Judy Bloom and of
course I walked as I was walking towards
her I just started balling and she held
my hands and said don't worry it happens
to all the ladies your
age and then when we saw the movie we
went to the premiere this past
spring uh and I I remember reading the
screenplay and being very disappointed
that uh Rachel mcadam's character was
given so much space in the film because
it wasn't just focused on Margaret and
I loved uh her bringing in the
generations into the film and I loved
what Rachel McAdams brought to it and
how I could see my own Journey as a mom
in the film and Judy Bloom said very
clearly that day at the premiere that
she couldn't believe it but she felt the
movie was better in the book and I have
to agree oh my God yeah and and it came
at a moment in our lives during the
pandemic when everyone was so isolated
when we got to be was really great
because especially for me I I was like
in my apartment with my parents and then
when we flew to North Carolina to film
I'm with all those kids and stuff and so
that was really great because we got to
hang out with be together and be in
community and make a story that had had
such huge impact yeah um well of course
that movie uh was very uh special in our
lives um but I I think if uh the thing
that uh the films
that uh had an impact on me were many
but uh the ones that when I was younger
that I watched that had a
different um uh impact on me where uh
John C vetti's films like um husband's
Woman Under the Influence just the way
he
decided uh
that it wasn't about the beautiful
camera shot it was about the people in
front of the camera and it didn't matter
if the camera wasn't Focus or if it had
film in it they were going to do it
anyway and there's an aspect of Alex and
Kelly like that um the way they are more
interested in what's what's going on
with the actors and and not worrying
about you know um the perfect framing or
the perfect shot or the more cinematic
beautiful shots not that
I I haven't seen the film yet so I
Beauty can't I don't know what the
framings are but um there's a lot of
beautiful I assume that but the the the
techniques that cavetti used that uh
that that I think also are uh echoed in
in their work is uh is what I really uh
uh responded to all good examples right
there yeah and I have a feeling that
ghost light is going to have that impact
on a lot of people when they start to
discover it at the festival and then
beyond to get into some specific moments
from filming this movie you've already
emphasized wonderful script right here
but I love hearing about the unexpected
magic that you can find on the spot so
can you maybe pinpoint the scene that
changed the most from script to screen
where something came up in the moment
and you held tight to it and ran with it
there's a lot of that um I can't there's
a scene that's not in the movie that's
like that though that was edited out the
original cut was 2 hours and 15 minutes
and we had to lose 20 minutes and we had
to lose this beautiful scene where um
like I don't even want to get into it
but a piece of magic happened and we
wanted to for a long time we tried to
preserve it and ultimately had to lose
it but um there were lots of little
moments here and there where an actor
would start to do something like
especially the family they would they
would we would just hear them on our
headphones sort of like talking to each
other arguing laughing and we would say
like can you just do that again and so a
lot of capturing their dynamic as a
family was part of that and I think you
gave Katherine the line about Leonardo
DiCaprio
yeah there's an ALT about River Phoenix
of course so but yeah the dinner table
scene I don't know if you remember where
where Katherine grabs a champagne bottle
um that was the first scene that we we
heard how powerful the character of
Daisy might actually be and that I
remember just spontaneously crying when
you give that final line in that scene
and I looked at Kelly and I was like oh
I was like we have to change the way
we're thinking about this so like the
the movie that was initially just like
it's just Dan suddenly became so much
more in the way we shot it about Dan and
Daisy about this father and daughter
because of like because of power and the
humor that Katherine brought to it it
just kind of like Justified opening up
this whole you know costume chest of
possibilities there was a scene where
they're getting ready for the deposition
um where there was originally no
scripted lines and then uh Tara and
Keith were like oh I would shave for
this deposition like you were like I
would shave for this and we were like
well continuity wise we can't do that so
they improvise these lines about like
aren't you going to shave and he was
like well I forgot and then uh you
were like we don't have time and then
Keith is like Well why'd you bring it up
that it was just like perfect and that
that has a real life yeah yeah that the
there were moments that weren't scripted
that felt like they were so natural and
their Dynamic was so rich that we were
able to just be like okay just turn the
camera on we kind of created like a
little engine like with that scene it
was like Katherine's in the other room
and she's saying on come on come on and
just you know that was like the impetus
and it's like okay explore that and
these two have to get ready and so
there's certain things they have to do
um that's funny actually guys you did
improvise quite a bit we did now that
you mention
it entire scenes also when it comes to
deleted scenes I know it's hard to let
them go but I'm also a big believer that
those deleted scenes you could still
feel influencing everything that does
make the finished cut so there is Great
Value in them oh absolutely 100% yeah
the scene that we had to cut Sharon
tells us a lot about their relationship
that they met when they were really
young and not to make any choices when
you're young because you can't even
grasp consequences and that's right we
lose all my backstory I know but here's
the great thing about your acting we
don't need it yep there you go it's true
though you feel the history and the
weight and that's that's what's
important ultimately in the end for the
three of you again family I know you're
all well aware of how talented each
other are but can you each tell me about
a time on set when you looked at another
and said to yourself like I knew you
were good but like I didn't realize you
were capable of doing
that
um um because I know if I if I let my
parents my mom go she's going to steal
my answer so I think for my dad I think
um during the deposition scene um during
his big big part I think that was I
didn't like I've never see my dad do
stuff like that it's usually like I'll
see him in plays and stuff and he never
really gets like like that he never lets
that emotional you know it's usually
either anger or comedy with so I so I
thought that in real life too yes in
real life too many that was really
impressive um just two yeah yeah but I
really loved that moment yeah yeah great
example um I I met Keith uh in college
when when we were 19 and uh he was doing
a production of um
of the Jack Nicholson
play's nest and he came out on and I got
dragged to it and I was like this is
going to be terrible it's it's a twoyear
cup it was a bad production but Keith
came out on stage and I was
like uh who's that guy and he's going to
be mine and then I took six years to
make him fall in love with me where's
this going it's going in the direction
that um he's always been my favorite
actor and every time I see him on stage
or uh on camera I fall in love with him
and it makes uh me not you know divorce
him and uh so I I expected him to be as
wonderful as he is in this um I love
working with him he's my favorite scene
partner we've done a lot of play
together and so I I I anticipated that
the whole way through and I was so
excited for Keith to get to show all of
the gifts that he has that I know he has
and so that was really exciting
but to see Catherine
um bring the um depth that she brings to
this film and to not just play anger or
to not just be loud and as the film
progressed towards the end of
filming to play somebody so complicated
and
empathetic sorry was really moving and
exciting and I'm incredibly proud of
her Keith how you follow that upti
answer as you should be I don't know how
to follow anything understandable um
yeah uh I would say that uh I'm I am
also proud of my daughter I um she um
the thing that I like about her
performance is that she would have these
impulses and she'd do something and
sometimes the camera is rolling and if
it wasn't I'd say when the camera's
rolling do that again because that's
that's honest and it's uh it's uh it it
it's it's not the uh the normal behavior
but it's not it's not outlandish or out
of character so that's what I always
look for that's the most interesting
stuff to do as an actor is to surprise
yourself and surprise the the the the
audience hopefully um and so that was
that was really fun to watch and uh Tara
is also uh you know uh what she said
about being in a scene with me is the
same uh I I trust her implicitly and
there's nothing that she can do to throw
me off or well anything she does just
makes me better as an actor and makes
anybody that acts with her better so
um yeah you're all the coolest makes me
so happy and this is the way they are
like this is not they are this amazing
like truly fills my heart I'm going to
end with our filo question I I quite
love this question as I brought up
earlier they're all about putting the
creative power in the hands of the
artist so whether it's on this movie or
anything you've done in the past can you
give me an example of a time when
someone gave you the creative power and
maybe it was a time when you didn't even
expect to get
it Alex Thompson producing St
Francis because I never would have had
that movie made by anybody else and he
was like I think I would have finished
the script without him because he read
like the first 10 pages and he was like
you got to finish this and I'll find the
money and we'll make it was a beautiful
example
too I think and I'm not just saying this
but Kelly could do anything you know she
can do anything she can do it by herself
she doesn't need me and maybe I'm better
at raising money but all the other stuff
she could do it but she continues to ask
me to work with her and it's almost like
in in the like like a 15-year-old or
8-year-old who always wanted to be a
director is just so grateful that this
is the person that I fell in with
because she could be like off doing her
own thing and she's chosen to well
that's true but but they will they will
and um and I think and Ghostlight
specifically so we were going to
co-direct Mouse and then she Ghostlight
was going to be her solo thing and I
read the script for Ghostlight and I
read like the first I read the
principal's office scene and it was like
The Blood Hound scene which was the
first scene I I read in St Francis and I
was like ah this is just good it's
just good and I don't know where it's
going and I'm sure none of these themes
are going to be Revisited but this scene
is so good and I just like kind of at
first really soft begged and then
eventually like just straight up was
like please please please let me
co-direct this with you and um you
eventually said yes yeah I did yeah and
I'm glad yeah so my Mo my name is on the
movie um which is the proudest thing I
love this movie I love love these people
you haven't seen it Keith I know but
what are you proud of just proud of
yourself proud you made your
days yeah that call sheet was real
nice I I was standing in the garage of
my theater company in Chicago loaning a
bunch of props to these guys for the
Shakespeare stuff and um they said uh
well are you going to you're going to be
in the film right and I was like uh oh
and they said have Kelly said have you
read it and I said no Keith had had it
for months and she said has Keith told
you about it I said not really and then
she said well I'll send it to you if you
want to do it we want you to do it and
then I read it and I was so blown away
that I had the and then two weeks later
we started filming two weeks
later and for me to have been offered a
role in this just offered a role in this
Alex had never met me you got a great
reel
thank God that contagion scene is
excellent but I was just I mean and from
the moment we set foot on it we were uh
offered uh the opportunity to create
these people
ourselves um we were offered the
opportunity to to talk to Kelly and Alex
as partners in crafting um our arcs and
our
Journeys we clothed ourselves yeah yeah
sorry about that we did not have
wardrobe or hair makeup but but I mean
it we were Partners on this entire
journey and I have never been a part of
something where I felt that much
ownership over the role that I was
crafting so I would have to say ghost
light yeah I I would say ghost light too
because uh unbeknownst to me uh Kelly
had written the role for me and and then
when I
unbeknown it was he knew
that you didn't know while I was writing
I I I didn't know the first time I read
it in the in the table read um and uh
you know I would never have had this
opportunity to be a lead in any movie
nobody would ever do that for me and so
uh that was it was it was Unreal um and
it was a one and a million chance and
and I'm so grateful for both of them and
uh seriously they
have one of the best sets I've ever
worked on and uh because I've only
worked as a you know
Hired Hand and if you know you say
something out a line they bounce you but
um you know uh it was great everybody
was great uh it's trickle down right
Luke and Wilson everybody Alex never
loses his cool things would go wrong and
he would smile and say we'll figure it
out we'll figure it out always go wrong
the the gunshots and hiding in the
Bas there was shooting down the street
we had to hide in the base that's though
what can you say Catherine sorry and
also Sor about that you made this you
shot this movie in October and it's here
at Sundance in January like my brain
cannot process how that's possible we
don't really know I mean it's our
editors yeah we they we cut we cut while
we film and so four days after we
wrapped we had a rough cut we even
forgot a scene and had to go shoot it on
Halloween yeah sure did Catherine came
up dressed or not you weren't dressed
like Dorothy but eventually dress like
Dorothy um it was wild but really I hope
that some of the filmmakers here at
Sunday and some of the amazing
filmmakers see these guys on screen and
start start calling them because they
they will fill up any you know they fit
in in any fantastic director's work and
I I hope I hope they start getting those
calls because they're amazing I will
100% get behind that statement before I
close out Katherine do you want to add
anything yeah I would have to say ghost
light too
um because I think on Margaret I was
there for only two months and I think
even though this was obviously a shorter
film this like I was there the whole
time but you laughing but that's like
not funny because um so I don't know why
you're laughing because it was a really
long shoot yeah it was like a 6mon shoot
and so we were only there for a part of
it so being here for the whole thing
it's a three Monon shoot no it wasn't
all right they took a Hiatus and then
they came back for like two more months
this is when we would start rolling the
cameras
exactly anyway I think being there and
like um I don't know if either of my
parents said this but like you could ask
Luke who's the cameraman or like the
cinematographer yeah cinematographer and
um or like Austin who was the sound
mixer like you could ask them about like
oh what are you doing right now and they
would just tell you you know so it was
really like learning how to make a movie
you know and I think that that was
something that you don't really ever
experience and I think that was super
special so yeah we won't keep you all
here all day just stay here I have to
let you go and promote your movie even
more because seriously this deserves to
be seen by the widest possible audience
huge congratulations on ghost light
thank
much